oui vous venez d'avoir jean ping le
président chinois qui a inauguré un pont
bien particulier aujourd'hui olivier
donc il s'agit du pont le plus long du
monde
oui il ya une petite spécificité c'est
le plus long pont maritime du monde
alors il ya des banques sont plus longs
et plus et notamment des ponts
ferroviaires en chine
mais là c'est le plus longtemps avec de
l'eau qui engendre donc une rivière je
remonterai ça sur cartes qu'on comprenne
bien chine non ça va donc au sud a
encore et on veut nous manquons plus
alors vous le voyez deux pôles sont
extrêmement important de courir en
également bakar alors le pont va relier
les deux ans à droite est également
savoir permettre aux gens d'aller plus
vite donc entre les deux endroits ont
par avance après les quatre heures hong
kong macao parce que regarder qui saigne
une baie ici alors faudrait vraiment
contourner la baie et on parle d'une
zone métropolitaine de 75 millions déjà
seulement dans cet endroit alors
imaginez-vous de circulation alors là
maintenant je reprend à peu près 45
minutes à l'encontre on cogne également
macao
je vous montrais le pan lors de sa
construction vous le voyez plusieurs
plusieurs images qu'on peut voir un peu
partout donc sur le site internet
construction a recommencé à 2009
après quoi environ 9 ans pour le faire
on parle d'un ouvrage de 25 milliards de
dollars mais eu toutes sortes de
problèmes il ya sept ouvriers notamment
qui sont morts plusieurs blessés
également la corruption lieu également à
toutes sortes de retard mais finalement
donc on ne peut faire l'inauguration
aujourd'hui regardez ce pont qui est
magnifique
d'ailleurs on l'appelle à peu le serpent
de mer garder son espèce de serpent de
mer et tout auto c'est le delta de la
rivière ou perles ce nom magnifique
effectivement alors vraiment comme on
dit ça relie ces deux points sont
importants d'un côté vous savez encore
qui est un centre financier de l'autre
côté macao
oui c'est un peu après deal atlantic
city la chine compterait plusieurs
casino casino sont là oui avec aussi
donc une activité nocturne qui est
importante alors vous le voyez donc ce
pont qui est vraiment vraiment
magnifique
regardez le premier véhicule finalement
kg foulée vous voyez donc c'est un
autobus aujourd'hui a dû le gagner le
poste à péage qui traiterait imposerait
aussi combien cinq dans la traversée
ça coûte pêche écoutez je vous avoue que
je ne sais pas moi je regardais sur les
dépêches le meilleur et pas cette
information là mais ça prend notamment
un permis spécial et toute sorte
d'autorisation effectivement pour
traverser le pot vous dire également
terminé que pour la chine c'est pour
notamment conserver ou sa vie ça m'a mis
deux anciennes colonies encore été
rétrocédée en 1997 à la chine et macao
quitté portugaise donc jusqu'en 1999 et
on se pose la question du style le pont
de la confédération qui le plus long
pont évidemment donc au canada sa
longueur parce que le pont chinois ses
55 km alors regardez celui ci 12 900 km
alors quand même plus petits oui mais
quand même imposant également alors une
inauguration évidemment qui ne passe pas
inaperçu bon voilà bah on avait
l'impression de prendre le bateau pour
aller vers une magnifique île lorsqu on
le faisait à l'époque maintenant le fera
finalement en voiture en voiture pour
m'informer sur le prime c'est pourri ça
va coûter quelques mois merci au revoir